so excited for bill and ted face the
music it's gonna be a total blast from
the past
yeah dude you know what else can feel
like a total blast from the past
giant panda king today's video sponsor
no way
that's what i was gonna say dude you're
a poet
and you didn't even realize that you
were actually doing a rhyme that's cool
if you're a totally excellent follower
of this channel you've heard us mention
gpk before
the folks who take fandom and creativity
to the next level
best known for their burlesque cabaret
show the empire strips back
set in the star wars universe oh those
ladies are hot i love
hot ladies how's it going ladies
speaking of ladies we read from cover to
cover their wookie erotica mags which
are like 70s playboy magazines set in
the star wars universe
it's definitely not bogus what i really
want to mention is this book that i ate
up in two incredible days it's called
gotham 1919-19
dudes no 39 39
it's a wildly different position it
takes the characters and mythology of
batman and reimagines them as part of
depression-era american history from the
war to end all wars to the crash of the
stock market from enforcement of
prohibition to the rise of celebrity
gangster
some of you folks out of the reject
nation have already purchased this book
and given such incredible
feedback it's so worth it so continue to
party on dudes by visiting gpk
today
[Music]
we're gonna get more of him in the
trailer
therapy do you think this is what they
had in mind
definitely i mean we're a couple of
couples oh they're back
get real jobs
my excellent friends we have a problem
step forward a song created by preston
and logan
performed tonight we'll save reality as
we know it
[Music]
we're stealing it from ourselves
i'll check the credits
by himself
[Music]
oops
[Laughter]
oh so excited oh
something tells me those daughters are
gonna steal the show whenever they're on
screen
yeah yeah because bill says woke now i
mean it's woke
it's probably a good way to segue them
out of some of the less
uh you know modern sensibilities of the
earlier films i make a sarcastic comment
and then john makes a sincere comment
i'm looking at imdb
that is kid cudi how funny
maybe eminem will show up too because i
was like wait a minute is that him but
that kind of looks like
no pun intended a kid
i'm like he looks incredibly white
i was way too young i was taken i was
taken back by that man so i found out a
little bit before filming this and the
amount of notification bells i saw
this is coming out on video on demand
now it's supposed to come out in
select theaters whatever theaters are
actually open i would adore this sit
seeing this at a drive-in or something
like that i think this could be a very
exciting movie to watch like absolutely
in the theater
hey i'd love to see it in the theaters i
think you know the idea of a drive-in i
hear it can be kind of an awkward
experience right now
just because of the way the reggae i
don't know i saw dad merle's video
recently and i was like i never consider
all these other factors and to go to a
drive-in theater i still think this
could be
a lot of fun because you could look
around and i think everyone would kind
of be in unison is celebrating bill and
ted face the music for the amount of
nostalgia it brings
the sentimentality that it brings and
there's something to be said about it
going on video on demand like letting
them have it that doesn't feel
like some marketing compromise because
this movie is
it really feels like this movie is made
for the fans this movie is meant to
be lifted together yeah yeah exactly and
so it's kind of like a weird gift
that we'll have to pay for it but it's a
weird gift you know you think back to
the end of the second movie and there's
so many people around the world
watching as you know this big you know
concert goes down
and i feel like they're almost going to
embody that with the way they release
this
because it does feel like a gift more
than just a oh what do we do
to be fair i mean orion isn't the
biggest studio so i think it probably
makes sense for them
to not wait on a theatrical because you
know it looks like they put some money
into this too because the
effects look way more advanced than the
previous ones true that i'm excited for
it looks
really creative looks awesome looks so
funny we're getting so much of like the
other characters the world
and all these other all the other bill
and ted universe building
things speaking of which looks like
they're probably going to some weird
multiverse
yeah i was going to say with the like
guns and roses version of themselves and
the
jacked up prisoners version of
themselves i wonder if they are going to
expand beyond just
simple time travel simple time driver
you know the rules of time travel that
we all you all know that we all know
there's never any issue with the movie
no one ever debates that
i was looking at collider's article just
now and they said on their description
that billy and thea who i'm assuming are
the daughters
uh they round up famous musicians to
help write the songs that will save the
world
that was an exciting aspect of this
trailer to me because you know the first
trailer really clues you in that there
will be a hell presence of some kind
you'll get death
it brought that element in in a way
where i was like oh like when they
started going and they have the woman
playing the flute and the guy in the
powdered wig i was like oh are we
actually gonna do a little bit of each
bill and ted movie and then maybe
add some extra with a multiverse like do
some historical figures go back to hell
in heaven and then also expand
beyond that or something well they had
that thing where they said that people
were going to be submitting like
uh i don't know singing or dancing and
then somehow they would choose some
people to be included in this like just
fans could be included in this movie so
i imagine it'll be
somehow mixed in with whatever montage
that is that people
may be helping out and you know like how
in bill and ted excellent adventure they
have these famous historical figures
i'm wondering i don't know if any of
these might be qualified as
too soon but i'm wondering if there's
any past musicians
like from the 60s or 70s who have passed
on if
they'll have them like appear like pull
them out of the afterlife and pull them
in here
oh that'd be fun i mean unless but it
might be insensitive though if they're
pulling them out of hell and then we're
saying some of these musicians went down
maybe they'll go to heaven in this one i
guess it depends on which musician
you know i mean if you had like somebody
want to see that music
yeah that's the question it's the
resurrecting dimebag daryl from hell i
don't think anybody's gonna be like what
an
insult to his good name because you know
pantera is pretty heavy
i think there's going to be a lot of
heart with this movie it's cool that
that with the trailer
they're putting the daughters more front
and center than before like they're
evidently the main supporting characters
while bill and ted are on their journey
you'll have
the daughter's billion as atheia going
on
their adventure as the main b story
that'll collide together
in the finale so you can already see the
whole movie and not just about the
details and getting all the comedy in
there and the wild zaniness involved but
of course
william frickin so
he's like one of my favorite on-screen
deaths ever what's great about
his character is that because he's in
that specific kind of makeup
it doesn't look like he's age day yeah
yeah because he could easily
death is not supposed to age so the fact
that he's in that makeup you could
totally mask whatever aging william
sadler has gone through in the last
couple decades
i mean i'm excited about that kind of
stuff too because what this trailer gave
us more than the last one
also is just what the present day for
bill and ted looks like and
even ted's dad is there basically saying
you guys never did any of this stuff
like
you're crazy yeah um so i also wonder if
maybe
i'm curious to see what the status quo
has been like for death before they
you know go back out on another
adventure or something like that and
what their
what their wives are back i was happy to
see that they actually brought them back
yeah because it would be really easy not
to and i think the one
one of the things that is less apparent
about this franchise
now that it's a full-on franchise is
that they have kept so much in the
family
beyond just alex winter and keon reeves
i mean like writers
have been doing this since the first one
they said whoever is alive we're
bringing them back
yeah yeah and like it really is cool
when a friend when a series goes from
the 80s into 2020 and and manages to
keep all those pieces together and i
think that
elevates the heart all right guys well
what do you think of bill and ted face
the music
if it comes out in the theaters if any
theaters are open in september
in your hometown will you go there will
you watching a drive-in will you get it
on video on demand let us know down
below you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell to get notified whenever we got a
new youtube video up especially if
there's something coming out at comic
con that we
want to cover last but not least let's
do a p
niraj krishnan i wanted to shout out
niraj specifically on this video because
with the amount
of varying rock music this guy
sends my way and john's way i think it's
time
to stop whatever accounting things
you're doing and
actually pursue your real passion
sending people music video requests and
getting paid for that
dude there's no shortage of requests
needed
you know i'm just messing with you man i
really feel like your heart
is in music i want to encourage you to
if you whatever musical things you're
good at doing
do more of that it'll make you feel
better it'll make you feel more
fulfilled so keep your job sure
especially because that keeps you
pledged you know what i mean
if you want to dabble into creating
music do that if you just want to talk
about music do that but inject some more
of it into your life because it seems
like a definite
passion and also stay pledged whoa john
whoa what don't
sound desperate oh i'm so sorry the
music that's it's all about the music
man it's not about the money
it's about the music video's way too
long keep it real